Google Cloud vision is a powerful image
analysis tool delivered through an
intuitive API cloud vision recognizes
and understands a broad set of entities
inside of an image it can read text
human emotions even knows that this
mango was with high confidence a mango
but at Google we take moonshots we
thought could these api's do more the
idea came one day when Miles said to me
Michele does this look too normcore to
you and I I had no idea today we're
sharing the newest feature the cloud
vision API style detection now vision
can tell you not only what clothes
you're wearing what that might say about
you imagine fashion based on data not
feelings that would be a better dressed
world we knew we needed experts for this
project so we invited fashion
consultants even elite teenage bloggers
to help us figure this out style is in
tension enigmatic even it's not just
about patterns or pleats or when to wear
white a style is an art it's an instinct
can it be taught I don't know there is
eco chic and boho chic and geek chic
fuzzy gosh I forgot those are good
there's a whole chic list like humans
teaching machines takes time and the
larger the training corpus the better
our predictions will be we've analyzed
millions of images a line skirts fedoras
you name our mantra here at Google is to
launch early and iterate so that's
exactly what we did on this project
we set up a live testing environment in
order to analyze an even more diverse
set of personal styles
made adjustments when needed and
fine-tuned the algorithm as our training
corpus continued to grow
we discovered that fashion exists not on
the industries but in the clouds this is
a new beginning in fashion history we're
excited to bring style detection to the
world because fashion touches all of us
you only get a few chances to make a
first impression sign up for the Alpha
today